[Musique]
karl olive bonjour à montigny le
bretonneux ainsi pas loin de vos terres
vos terres de poids si vous êtes élu
maire vous êtes aussi le vice président
du conseil départemental des yvelines et
deuxième vice-président de la communauté
urbaine du grand paris seine et oise
voilà pour les présentations rapides on
va parler de votre engagement de vos
engagements
notre parcours également et vous avez
plusieurs vies plusieurs vies
professionnelles en tout cas à bientôt
à 49 ans avant la politique vous étiez
journaliste
ouais carte de presse 1989 18 ans
qu'elle commence à 160 6 956 alors si on
était dans des numéros ah oui mais
jamais son héros et j'ai beaucoup
d'émotion quand je vois évidemment le le
vélodrome nationale ici où on aura les
jeux olympiques évidemment c'est un
endroit que je connaissais pas ici je
suis ravi de le découvrir
et dans quelques semaines on sera avec
le variétés club de france pour jouer à
voir si chez notre collègue et ami
philippe benassaya
ça va me rappeler juste c'est bamba où
j'étais sur le terrain à canal et j'en
suis ravi la carte de presse canal+ on
va parler un petit peu de tout ça le
premier poste que vous avez pu occuper
ce sont 1 chez nos confrères qui ont
disparu en tout cas sous la forme
actuelle c'est yvelines première c'est
irresponsable des sports vous avez été
ensuite directeur d'antenne jusqu'en
quels souvenirs vous gardé de cette
époque là tout simplement formidable
formidable une école de la vie à nul
autre pareil j'ai beaucoup d'émotion
d'ailleurs quand je vous en parle parce
que j'ai vu passer des gamins qu'avait
qui avait 16 ans qui viennent en stage
qui sont aujourd'hui rédacteur en chef à
m6
j'ai vu passer dès aujourd'hui des
présentateurs et présentatrices qui sont
à elle c'est qu'ils sont atef
ça a été une école de formation qui m'a
beaucoup appris et convaincu que
l'apprentissage était vraiment un
passeport pour l'emploi
là où aujourd'hui encore certains
considèrent par une voix par défaut ça
ça a été formidable
et puis quand on est journaliste vous
savez wilfried le matin vous réveillez
vous c'est parce que vous allez avoir
dans votre canard le soir ici on est à
montigny à 100 100 maisons cessant
reportage différents ça c'est le sel
véritablement de ce métier et comme je
le dis on n'est pas journaliste
habitants c'est de l' enthousiasme avoir
toute chose n'est pas journaliste à mi
temps et cette passion vous l'avez
continué ensuite à canal vous l'avez
mentionné le groupe canal canal + et i
télé est encore une fois pour parler de
sport
woods principalement sport mais pas
seulement et canal c'est c'est l'endroit
j'irai où il fallait être à l'époque les
meilleurs journalistes de la place de
paris et tête était à canal moi je
rêvais quand j'étais gamin neutre avec
michel denisot
j'ai eu le bonheur le privilège d'être
avec monsieur denisot pendant pendant
dix ans ça a été formidable
je lui ai simplement dit le jour où il
m'a nommé directeur des sports michel
tes décisions sont mes décisions
mes décisions sont tes décisions on a
travaillé main dans la main avec un
esprit d'équipé que j'essaye de
conjuguer au quotidien aujourd'hui dans
dans cette nouvelle vie qui est une vie
d'engagement locale il ya deux passions
pour pourtant ce qui vous concerne en
tout cas sur la première partie de votre
vie c'était le journalisme et puis le
sport et le football carrière de
dirigeant sportif président du club de
football de château de poissy aussi et
alors vous avez même signé en 2003
basile boli
ouais d'abord le football c c'est un adn
de la famille olive moi je suis issu
d'une famille nombreuse on était huit
mes cinq frères jouer au football
j'avais une soeur on a tous cru devenir
footballeur professionnel
il y en a un qui a réussi ou plutôt une
c'est ma soeur qui a été international
qui est aujourd'hui membre du cio qui
porte la coupe du monde 2019 de football
de football en france football féminin
et qui est aujourd'hui secrétaire
général de la fédération française de
football donc on a toujours vraiment
nous vécu alors du coup marianne
foutrein et ils football laden football
winfried sais c'est la passion de
l'équipe dans une équipe de football
vous avez des patrons comme je le dis
vous avez des patrons des cadres des
chômeurs on a tous la même tunique et on
se on se trompe pas d'objectif et gym ya
beaucoup de synergies et je trouve que
devenir du sport quand on aujourd'hui on
fait la politique ça nous facilite le
j'ai presque envie dire le jeu vous avez
joué aussi au football avec le paris
saint germain ouest germain qui
maintenant va venir s'entraîner on n'a
qu'à prochainement sur vos terres aussi
de la première licence au paris
saint-germain j'avais 13 ans et puis le
jour où j'ai compris que je pourrai pas
aller le plus haut possible j'étais en
cadets nationaux paris saint germain
je suis devenu arbitre pour le paris
saint-germain arbitre jeunes arbitres de
la fédération française de football et
quand j'ai atteint mon seuil de peters
voilà moi il faut absolument que je suis
un compétiteur né voilà un mot tout de
même sur le psg parce que passionné du
psg forcément déçu oui déçu alors déçu
déçu pas par rapport au real de madrid
parce que le real de madrid était plus
fort quand on est plus fort il faut se
poser des questions pour savoir comment
on peut être plus fort que le plus fort
voilà donc pas déçu sur ce match-là déçu
sur le match aller bonjour parce que
quand vous menez 1 0 que vous avez la
possibilité de gagner 2 0 quand vous
raté des occasions que vous n'êtes pas
suffisamment encore une fois compétition
que là la chance entre green bay ne vous
sourit pas il faut se poser les bonnes
questions aux hésitations sinon il faut
il faut changer des choses moi je dis
que le travail entraîne le talent le
talent entraîne la chance et la réussite
on peut rien faire sans travail et sans
talent il ya du travail peut-être qu'il
en faut de façon supplémentaire
il ya du talent peut-être pas
suffisamment et puis le jour où il y
aura un peu plus de travail un peu plus
de talent alors on aura la chance et la
réussite
elle nous a fuis au match aller elle
nous a pas manqué puisqu'on avait pas de
raison d'avoir de la chance on n'a pas
été suffisamment compétiteurs par
rapport au real en semaine dernière d'un
pronostic y aura beaucoup de départ au
psg cet été
écoutez sénat mais c'est la vie d'un
cycle c'est la vie d'un cycle moi je
suis malheureux d'entendre que cavani va
peut être quitter le club parce que
c'est un formidable d'abord c'est un
formidable joueur et c'est un homme
formidable également c'est un bel homme
cavale il a des qualités humaines encore
une fois nulle autre pareille voilà
après c'est le jeu c'est important
d'avoir je dirais de nouveaux joueurs
c'est le sait le cycle de la vie du
football club de la vie tout court
d'ailleurs on en parle maintenant de on
en parle maintenant de politique
puisqu'il a fallu franchir ce cap
qu'est ce qui vous a fait changer
d'orientation professionnelle
la passion du terrain le pardon de le
dire l'amour de l'autre quand on est
engagé localement mais je suis déjà posé
si j'ai grandi à pau si je vous disais
famille nombreuse et trois garçons mon
épouse
évidemment via précis on a travaillé à
potins ya possiblement mon père a le
40-50 crémerie chez psa mes quatre
frères travaillaient à l'épaule chrysler
à l'époque école d'apprentissage
ils ont jamais eu de problème de travail
etc je crois que c'est la passion de
l'autre aimer les gens ça s'apprend pas
dans le dictionnaire
en revanche quand vous aimez les gens
les gens sur le terrain vous le sentez
et encore une fois les n'y a pas de code
il n'y a pas de bac + 12 et c'est assez
voilà on a le contact et le feeling moi
j'ai toujours été dans la proximité
toujours que ce soit avec le le sport
que pâques mais l'association autour de
poissy j'ai toujours été dans la
proximité et sur l'engagement de terrain
et je suis ravi de voir que les
administrés en 2014 me l'ont tellement
rendu est qu'aujourd'hui je me nourris
de projet au service de mes administrés
et ça c'est important
un exemple winfried on est là la seule
ville je pense de france à préparer nos
conseils municipaux dans les quartiers
tous les mois tous les mois je prépare
mes conseils municipaux dans les
quartiers et je change de quartier tous
les mois ça dure deux heures on en prend
plein la figure
on se demande si on vit parfois dans la
même commune mais ça fonctionne je pense
que les administrés sont capables de
tout entendre ce qui va bien il est
aussi ce qui va mal simplement ils
veulent voir le patron ils veulent voir
les élus ils veulent voir parfois les
partenaires les promoteurs et c'est pour
leur dire ce qui se passe ce qu'il pense
et à partir de là chacun prend ses
responsabilités
adhésion à l'ump est en 2010 pourquoi le
choix de la droite parce que je suis un
homme de droit que je me considère ans
il fallait le dire plus tôt dans une
obédience sociale humaniste etc
je crois que pouvait l'avoir défini il
ya quelques instants et puis par contre
de reprendre ce problème ma ville je
pense qu' il est plus facile d'apprendre
à pêcher à quelqu'un que de lui donner
du poisson tous les jours c'est un peu
voilà je pense qu'aujourd'hui le salut
vient du développement économique
l'idée de dire que tout doit venir en
terme de finances des collectivités
locales territoriales de communes
urbaines
ça s'est fini c'est c'était avant pour
reprendre l'expression d'un ancien
président aujourd'hui le service et le
développement économique et le
développement économique c'est qui ce
sont les entreprises
c'est pour ça que je joffre évidemment
des conditions aux entreprises qui
veulent venir s'installer à poissy où
sur le territoire parce que encore une
fois c'est un travail d'équipé et à ce
titre là oui je me considère comme un
homme de droite que j'assume
un homme de droite ce qui signifie pas
un homme
un homme des républicains voilà on va y
venir tout de même parce que vous n'êtes
plus aujourd'hui à 0 aux républicains
j'ai parlé mais ce n'est pas l'avis de
laurent wauquiez annonçant je ne
soutiens pas mais dans une chapelle il
ya plusieurs voilà il ya plusieurs
sensibilités
j'aimerais simplement qu'il n'y ait pas
de clivage à ce point où sous prétexte
qu'on ne fait pas partie d'une
sensibilité qui est la même que celle du
patron entre guillemets ou du président
tout de suite on soit évacué qu'on
entende plus personne parler moi comme
vous le savez j'ai créé porte paroles
d'alain juppé on s'est mis derrière
françois fillon au début de son de son
engagement ce n'est pas un chèque en
blanc à partir du moment où on a vu ce
qui se passait j'ai sonné la sonnette
d'alarmé
comme un certain nombre n'était pas très
nombreux et parcours de notre ère oui
mais pardon de le dire on a eu ce qu'on
méritait et il faut le dire
et de l'autre côté il faut féliciter
emmanuel macron qui a réussi à a explosé
tous ses codes et je suis pas toujours
d'accord avec ce que fait le président
macron mais force est de constater
qu'aujourd'hui quand on est sur le
terrain on nous parle pas politique mais
on nous parle de terrain c'est pour ça
que moi je crois véritablement à
l'engagement de terrain et votre suite
de carrière politique vous la voyez sous
quelle bannière alors écouter à chaque
jour suffit sa peine
moi encore une fois je me revendique
comme un homme de droite sociale
humaniste et je pense qu'aujourd'hui
d'abord la meilleure politique c'est
celle du bon sens c'est du bon sens et
celle du terrain donc aujourd'hui
génération terrain et je le revendique
comme un certain nombre d'ailleurs des
administrés je le vois bien dans le
contact qu'on peut avoir et dans les
échanges qu'on peut avoir y compris
d'ailleurs avec le président du conseil
départemental
je pense qu'on est sur la vérité et la
vérité c'est celle c'est celle du
terrain et puis après il écoute et on a
notre prochain notre prochaine séquence
je dirais ce sera ce sera le municipal
je serai pas élu parce que je suis un
homme de tel parti ou tel parti c'est
pas ça je serai d'abord élu si le bilan
a parfaitement convenu et satisfait les
administrés et ça c'est ça qui m'a qui
m'apporte le reste chaque jour suffit sa
peine vous avait devancé ma prochaine
question c'est l'action locale pour vous
qui prime ou est ce qu'il ya un moment
l'action nationale aussi pourrait vous
intéresser
moi je crois d'abord que quand on est
maire de pau si je suis un jeune berger
et élus en 2014
il faut vraiment installé faire le
terrassement le postulat et ça ça passe
par les projets ça passe par les projets
moi je suis arrivé dans une
dans une ville où il y avait 250 agents
excédentaire où on avait 8 millions de
trop déjà avant même de commencer le
budget on a fait 5 millions d'économies
de budget de fonctionnement en quatre
ans ce qui m'a permis de ne pas
augmenter la pression fiscale locale
cela m'a permis d'avoir le même niveau
de service à la population et le même
niveau d'investissement et au delà de ça
on accueille le paris saint germain avec
250 millions d'investissements à la clé
on va voir amusé le corbusier
on entre on travaille pour avoir un
tramway on à 3200 personnes de psa qui
viennent de façon supplémentaire là où
on indiquait que l'industrie automobile
se portait mal c'est formidable quand
même pour nous pour une ville comme
comme la ville de poissy et quand j la
ville de poissy
j'ai une des villes de la communauté
urbaine et c'est le travail d'équipé
moi je ne peux rien faire aujourd'hui et
je le dis si je n'ai pas le soutien du
conseil départemental et de son présent
pierre bédier si j'ai pas le soutien de
la communauté urbaine et grand paris
seine et oise et de soutien de philippe
poutou la région de france avec valérie
pécresse c'est un travail d'équipé
je pense que le temps où chacun possède
son côté comme je le dis souvent en
structure râteau ça c'est totalement
révolu c'est terminé il faut travailler
en équipe
seul on va plus vite ensemble on va plus
loin c'est ce que j'essaie de mettre en
place au quotidien pour terminer à 3 3
dernières questions et on va quitter un
peu le monde de la politique dernier
film que vous ayez vu le dernier film
que
j'ai marqué le dernier film qui met
marqué j'ai revu il ya pas très
longtemps philadelphia qui m'avait
marqué lors de sa sortie c'était en 1992
et qui continuent à nous marquer parce
que tom hanks est un acteur formidable
notre livre de chevet mon livre de
chevet s'appelle le
lemoine rouge le masne rouge dont le
film
va ressortir d'ici quelques semaines et
j'invite les téléspectateurs aller voir
ce film qui est tirée donc d'un ouvrage
qui s'intitule moindre rouge et pour
terminer le morceau que vous avez en
tête morceaux de musique vous savez que
vous ayez en tête en ce moment parce que
vous aimez tout de même la musique vous
avez rendu hommage avec la ville de
poissy aussi bien johnny hallyday qu'un
france gall j'adore la musique j'adore
la chanson française j'adore goldman qui
était le père des restos du coeur
les restos du coeur d'antan beaucoup
parlé c'est une pause aussi que je
soutiens et donc des
puisque tu pars puisque l'organe
puisqu'il n'est pas de frontières
au-delà donc ça c'est puisque tu pars de
jean goldman pense que c'est l'une des
plus belles chansons qui étaient écrites
que les uns et les autres se remémore
ses paroles auront autant de frissons de
journée au moment où je vous en parle
merci beaucoup karl olive
si le principe est à ce café politique
[Musique]
et